Kevin O'Leary is Mr Wonderful from Shark
Tank he was being interviewed uh we
showed you a couple clips of it being
interviewed by Tucker Carlson and he's
making the rounds and and Kevin O'Leary
from where I sit is a pretty sane cogent
guy who was an accomplished an awful lot
he has invested millions and millions if
not hundreds of millions of dollars into
all sorts of companies some of them
succeed some of them fail again that's
what it's all about competition
meritocracy try to make something create
something you someone else create
something you got to make a better round
strap it's all beautiful it's what
America is all about it's what the human
spirit is all about uh he now has had it
basically with everything coming out of
the Democrat Party The Machine the left
the progressives all of that stuff and
he's acknowledging that it's actually
destroying the blue States here he is
talking about New York and what AOC and
her ridiculous socialist policies uh
have done to New York and you're not
going to believe this if you watch the
end of this thing Don Lemon
I don't know how this happened this is a
bizarre day Don Lemon kind of agreed
with something that made sense what is
going on is there tequila in my coffee
thousands of jobs coming out of that I
mean that is that's New York
uninvestable sorry don't shoot the
messenger just telling you the way it is
that's it some pushback from our elected
officials in New York I'm not going to
say Kathy yeah but we'll debate them any
time of the day you want oh we would
love to see the AOC snap she's great at
killing jobs she kills jobs by that
thousands you know another New Jersey
problem
where did Amazon take their jobs they
took them away from her she threatened
to sue them if they created jobs I mean
this is a reality there's a reality that
there's a little more to it but let's
not really update that oh sorry I'm just
telling the truth he's saying what a lot
of people are saying especially what
happened with that Amazon thing here in
New York just lemon getting one right at
the end there absolutely incredible must
have been opposite day you can see the
way the other anchors look they want to
act as the litigators as the lawyers for
the Democrat policies right and of
course what he said what Mr Wonderful
said was I'll debate her I'll debate
hoko I'll debate AOC on this stuff any
day little just side anecdote about what
happened there with the AOC Amazon thing
you may remember Amazon was going to
bring a massive massive factory to New
York it was it was actually about uh 10
or 15 miles from my parents house the
house that I grew up in that my parents
are still at now for those few weeks
when when it looked like it was going to
happen house prices in the area spiked
because they were going to bring in
something like ten thousand I think it
might have even been more it doesn't
even matter what the exact amount number
is thousands of and thousands of new
jobs and what comes with new jobs is new
people moving into the community and
then you know what new people need they
need homes to live in so house prices in
my parents neighborhood were jumping
because they were going to have
competition on houses and then people
would have competed on house prices and
it would have been good for everybody
somebody that lived in say an
economically depressed area now Amazon
comes in holy cow we have a Starbucks on
our corner and the house prices are
going up and you're not going to believe
it now there's more tax money to go to
the system and their hot diggity dog
they're Paving the roads isn't that wild
but AOC killed the freaking thing and
she did it in the name of social justice
because we Must Destroy Amazon
[Music]